culture well and there also was the
abandonments okay of the you know of the
cannon okay people you know asserted
that the cannon was the product of bias
and again the you know of a of a you
know provincial elitism and so on but in
in point of fact as a student of history
of the arts okay I can I can show people
that the Canon okay oh the
overwhelmingly so is is the result of
what artists have determined okay we say
a work is important as canonical because
artists following it okay we're
influenced by it we have this like a
beautiful cascading tradition of
influence right so that that's the sort
of nothing but not another part of the
Philistine ozone okay of current
education to you know to believe that
there are these external reasons okay
for for that why a work last why a work
you know I'm written 500 years ago or a
thousand years ago has global you all of
us as if it's some sort of political
conspiracy it's based on power as if
anybody could even manage that no matter
how offeri ously were but also in the
60s even hadn't had the idea okay that
there wasn't like this human human
sensibility like that transcendent
individual if the nation's and and so on
right and that and that there was this
like rubric from cosmic consciousness
okay
this Sun this sense of the universe as a
whole and just to see the human being in
relationship to great eternal principles
of you have life into death mortality
and so on whereas you know Marxism is
blind Marxism is very narrow all it
ceases is a society okay
it sees nothing beyond society it
doesn't seem nature okay it's absolutely
mad how you can have a system being
taught okay in universities right which
it which thinks that this tiny thing of
society okay compared to the enormity
and beauty of nature okay okay it should
take all of our all of our you know
absorb all of our energy and attention
so I mean I just think that there's like
a parochialism and provincialism
you know
it now a kind of you know this
systematized elitism in our current
education and just got to be rooted out
and we I want to return to basics great
simplicity side all these faculty
members teaching their little tiny
courses that have to has to do with
their own specialty that's got to stop
okay people people can even pursue
whatever they want in their private
research as scholars okay
certainly that's necessary but they must
teach in the core curriculum and and and
people must decide what is crucial for
an educated person to know I do want a
multicultural I do want a global
curriculum I want I want all the
cultures taught okay right this is not
the answer
mark Marxism this neo Marxism in the
Universities okay is simply it's lazy
it's a lazy way to assert
multiculturalism without actually doing
the research and the study of other
cultures okay all right that's a good
one to close one we agreed on everything
I knew
[Music]